(upbeat music)
- The main thing people
think about Compton
is you go into Compton and
everybody's gang-banging at you
and shooting at you but
it's really not like that.
There have been times that
people have made rude comments
while we were at a competition.
One of the girls had said,
“Oh, they're from Compton,
they probably have bullet holes
in their barn or something.”
To ride for Compton, there
comes a sense of pride for it.
(gentle music)
My name is Shola Oyefeso, I'm 17 years old
and I'm a student at The
Compton Junior Posse.
- [Instructor] Looks great,
bend your knee though.
- A program that keeps kids
on horses and off the streets.
- I've been riding with
The Compton Junior Posse
for about six years now.
I am one of the more experienced
riders in the program.
I have learned a lot about myself.
I definitely have more patience
after working with horses.
Like, when I first started
riding at like 11 years old,
I used to always get in
trouble from attitude problems.
You come in with a bad
attitude when you're trying
to ride a horse and it
comes out through them, too.
It's like you're in sync with your horse,
you're supposed to be in
sync, it's a partnership.
(upbeat music)
We do have serious competitors at The
Compton Jr. Posse.
We go to a show per month just
to show what kind of progress that we’ve been doing
and what kind of work we’re doing with the kids.
We’re coming out there and
competing with the upper level people.
I came in fourth for the medal finals at the
Interscholastic Equestrian League Competition — that’s a big deal.
It is a stereotype that more people
in the horse world are white and rich,
but there are more people from different backgrounds
and different demographics
that are competing now; it feels
good to break the stereotype.